ان تعمل غايه جوده عالي تكمل الاتفاق حول
هذه النقطه المتبقيه قبل السادس من ابريل
واذا اكتملت يتم التوقيع خلال اليوم
السادس من ابريل
اخبار العالم بانجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره مرحبا بكم القوى المدنيه
والعسكريه في السودان تتفق على تحديد مده
خمسه ايام لحل القضايا العالقه وابرزها
دمج قوات الدعم السريع في الجيش والتوقيع
على الاتفاق النهائي الخميس المقبل
والمتحدث باسم العمليه السياسيه يؤكد
العمل على تجاوز الخلافات تمهيدا لتوقيع
الاتفاق مقتل احد عشر شخصا واصابه اخرين
باختناق اسراء حادث تدافعا للحصول على
مساعدات غذائيه مجانيه في مدينه كراتشي في
حين لقي سته اشخاص حتفهم الاسبوع الماضي
في حديثين مشابهين وذلك في ظل ارتفاع
اسعار السلع الاساسيه وتفاقم الازمه
الاقتصاديه تويتر تبدا ازاله علامه
التوثيق للحسابات التي لا تعود لمسؤولين
او لمنظمات حكوميه وبهذه الخطوه سيفقد
العديد من المشاهير العلامه الزرقاء ما لم
يشتركوا في الخدمه المدفوعه
ماسك الذي يسعى لزياده ايرادات تويتر قال
ان قراره يهدف لمحاربه سيل الحسابات
المزيفه غضب وجدل عبر مواقع التواصل بعد
قرار الاتحاد الفرنسي منع الحكام من ايقاف
المباريات للسماح للاعبين بالافطار خلال
شهر رمضان لجنه الحكام الفيدراليه التابعه
للاتحاد اعتبرت ايقاف المباريات هو اجراء
لا يحترم احكام نظامه الاساسي ومبدا حياه
كره القدم الى اللقاء